had some good dreams last night i drank
my ex-wife last night you guys still
talk no that's just so much i wish i
could take that time back chloe's always
been my favorite kardashian wow okay she
and kris jenner are neck and neck i'll
be honest how long are y'all married
four year i miss you so much who am i
hoping is in the big brother house i'm
hoping i'll bump into khloe kardashian
yeah that's what lamar told us before he
moved into the house last wednesday and
while that didn't happen it's clear he's
still got chloe on the brain and he's
not the only one rooting for them to be
reunited i am obsessed with them as a
couple kevin frazier really
i am i love love how often do you think
the name kardashian will be brought up
during this season because you also have
shayna mochler in there too
well i'm going like this every time
with my kombucha
um
because yes shayna mokler i know is not
um exactly thrilled that her ex-husband
travis barker who recently got engaged
to
kourtney kardashian and now that she's
living in the house with lamar odom
yeah that's going to be a whole separate
show i would like to play this game with
integrity but at the end of the day i am
ready to lie cheat and steal to win
[Applause]
we also have housewives in there since
we have cynthia bailey from atlanta
housewives we have teddy mellencamp
who's from beverly hills housewives
is that going to bond them or is there
going to be a dynamic a girl's got to do
what a girl's got to do our cameras are
going to be like
yes
so
these folks are celebrities they're used
to being in front of cameras do they
understand what's coming for them
because once you're in that house it
never ends there's no moment where you
get time off i think super fans like
todrick hall
gets it yes you know
uh but i think someone like chris kattan
who you know you know him from snl and
right at the box
i don't think she really knows what he
signed up for look at this look look
i don't think i'm going to be a very
ruthless player the new season of
celebrity big brother premieres tomorrow
night on cbs and host julie chen moonves
has her eye on this guy todd bridges you
and me both kevin pretty soon the knives
are gonna come out people's throats are
gonna start getting cut and then we're
gonna be sent home in body bag
you know my 12 year old son said to me
who's done bridges
son
you better sit down
and he knows the line like what you
talking about willis
i'm like where can we stream different
strokes for our whole weekend my money
is on todd bridges not only not just
because you know from my childhood of
you know watching him this guy is a
survivor he's been through a lot big
brother might seem like
nothing to him let the war begin
[Music]
you